federation has submitted documents
regarding allegations of biological
weapons programs in ukraine
as i informed the security council last
friday
the united nations is not aware of any
such biological weapons program
i would also like to note that the
united nations currently has neither the
mandate
nor the technical or operational
capacity to investigate this invest in
information as i previously informed the
council the relevant instrument of
international law
is the 1972 biological weapons
convention or bwc
which effectively prohibits
the development production acquisition
transfer stock piling and use of
biological and toxin weapons
the russian federation and ukraine are
both states parties to the biological
weapons convention
mr president
the bible school weapons convention
contains several measures to which
concerned state parties can have
recourse
in order to address situations in which
they have concerns or suspicions about
the activities of their peers
pursuant article 5 of the convention its
states parties undertake to consult one
another
and to cooperate in solving any problems
such consultation and cooperation can
take place on a bilateral basis between
the concerned state parties
or it can be undertaken through
appropriate international procedures
one such international procedure that
has been elaborated within the framework
of the biological weapons convention
is the convening of a consultative
meeting
other possibilities for addressing
concerns between states parties also
exist
under article 5 of the convention as
well as
under article 6.
as i mentioned last week the bwc needs
to be operationalized and
institutionalized to ensure it is
properly equipped and resourced to face
future challenges
the convention's upcoming ninth review
conference presents the ideal
opportunity for its state's parties to
comprehensively strengthen the
convention
the united nations office for
disarmament affairs stands ready to
support any procedures under the
biological weapons convention that
states parties may decide to use
mr president
turning to the issue of
the safety and security of ukraine's
nuclear power facilities
the director general of the
international atomic energy agency has
reported that
according to the ukrainian authorities
or safety systems at the zafarita
nuclear power plant remained fully
functional as of yesterday following the
site's loss of connection to a third
external power line
linking to
the national electricity grid
although officials from russia's state
nuclear power company were present
at the facilities in southern ukraine
ukrainian staff continue to operate the
plant
the chernobyl power plant remains
connected to the national electricity
grid following reconnection on 4th of
march
however ukrainian operators and guards
have not been able to rotate for 3 weeks
now
the iaea has reported that
according to the ukrainian authorities
eight of the country's 15 reactors
remained operating
i understand that regarding nuclear
safeguards the iaea is still not
receiving remote data transmission
from its monitoring systems installed at
chernobyl
but such data was being transferred to
iaea headquarters from the other nuclear
power plants in ukraine
take this opportunity to reiterate the
sector general support for efforts by
the iaea to establish a framework on the
safety and security of ukraine's nuclear
facilities
and urge all parties to work towards
this end
mr president
i wish to also highlight the terrible
toll this conflict is having on
civilians
the civilian casualties continue to rise
as of 16 march the office for the high
commissioner for human rights had
recorded
2032 civilian casualties
including 780 killed of whom 58 were
children
the actual number of casualties is
believed to be much higher
most of these casualties are caused by
the use of explosive weapons with a wide
area impact
these include attacks using heavy
artillery multiple launch rocket systems
ballistic and cruise missiles and air
strikes
i also want to reiterate that attacks
directed at civilians are prohibited by
international humanitarian law
we must find a diplomatic solution to
this war to put an end to the violence
as secretary general guterres said and i
quote
we need an immediate succession of
hostilities
and serious negotiations based on the
principles of the u.n charter and
international law
we need peace
peace for the people of ukraine
peace for the world we need peace now
i thank you very much for your attention
to the representative of the russian
federation
president
first of all allowing me to express
condolences
to
the post
the representative
that they've suffered this is obviously
a loss to the irish mission and for all
of us so
please accept our condolences
we've always already said that during
russia's special military operation in
ukraine information was discovered
regarding
the implementation of the ukrainian
authorities with the support and the
direct supervision of the u.s ministry
of defense of dangerous projects as part
of their military and biological
programme
this activity was carried out on the
territory of ukraine the centre of
eastern europe and in the western
borders of russia which created a real
threat for the biosecurity of our
country and the whole region
a week ago
on the request of the russian federation
there was the first security council
meeting held on this topic
here we asked our western colleagues a
series of questions but they haven't yet
responded to them the representative of
the us wasn't able to explain
how the statements of the american
officials about how there's allegedly no
u.s controlled biolaboratories on
ukraine how that tallies with the fact
of the present of documentary proof of
this kind of cooperation between kiev
and washington
recall here we're talking about a
agreement signed in 2005 between the u.s
minister of fence and the ministry of
health of ukraine which clearly sets
forth support for the pentagon to joint
biological research applicable to
dangerous pathogens located in
facilities
on ukrainian territory
although the american delegation
does not want to respond to our
questions
but they
are as much as the russian defense
ministry uh is aware
what uh materials we receive from
ukraine by laboratories about the
implementation of military biological
programs over the us and their nato
allies on ukrainian territory
over the last week
new details have come to light which
allow us to
stake that
components for biological weapons were
being created on the territory of
ukraine
the implementation of the aforementioned
american ukrainian agreement from 2005
and comments on which we're still
waiting for from the u.s representation
has been going full steam ahead for all
these years
however from the documentary we can see
that the american colleagues were not
helping as they claimed the ukrainian
ministry of health but rather the
ukrainian ministry of defense
security council document that we
distributed this morning
and you see in that material you can see
the so-called
technical assistance plan for certain
recipients
of the ukrainian ministry of defense i
recommend you to look at this document
very carefully
it confirms direct funding and
supervision of the pentagon
its defense threat reduction agency of
military and biological projects in
ukraine
the overall quantity of the funding was
32 million
directly
to the following laboratories in the
from the ministry of defense of ukraine
in kiev the 10th regional health
epidemiological department of the
central health epidemiological
department of the ukrainian ministry of
defense
in odessa the 27th regional uh health
epidemiological department of the
central
epidemiological department of the
ukrainian ministry of defense in levovov
the 28th regional
health
epidemiological department of the
central epidemiological department of
the ukrainian defense in harkov 108th
regional uh department of
[Music]
uh ukraine ministry of defence
epidemiological department i'd like to
draw your attention to one another
vitally important point
the representative of the us state
departments continue to model the
information and
ascertain that u.s
uh allegedly don't are not does not
operate in any biological laboratories
in the territory of ukraine but the
facts show otherwise
according to
the plan that i mentioned for technical
assistance the donor is the us ministry
of defense they established the tax the
tasks and the workload with as part of
the projects on ukrainian territory and
they said for a list of the necessary
equipment
and a delegated significant authority to
an affiliated contractor company black
and beach with cooperation
with ukrainian bodies of foreign
authority
the recipient of american assistance was
ukrainian defense ministry and they were
allowed timely access for pentagon and
contractor staff to laboratories on
ukrainian territory in order to carry
out work as part of these projects and
also to provide access to these
facilities
pentagon
staff foreign scientists too the
projects themselves
included implementing was it was
implemented not by the ukrainian
scientists scientists but with their
participations put simply the ukraine
authorities gave the pentagon carte
blanche on the territory of ukraine to
carry out
uh dangerous biological experiments
the american contractors at the same
time was free got a tax break under
ukrainian legislation
what did the ukrainian scientists
receive in return by either ukrainian
people free travel to international
conferences based on expenses for food
and accommodation as established by
uh for u.s civil servants
this kind of compensation
is carried out is is that's the
conversation provided for working
alongside dangerous biological science
this is not to
uh
noble assistance ukraine that the
american representatives talk about this
is cynical use of its territory and
population for dangerous research which
washington does not carry out on its own
territory so it doesn't run at risk of
hurting its own people we're not won't
be surprised if similar facts about
activities supervised by the us
appear in laboratories in other regions
of the world too we call on countries
who provide their territory for carrying
out this kind of experiments to the
pentagon to carefully study the
contracts for their cooperation with the
us on in the biological domain we fully
support require the
question from china to the u.s to share
the data of the activity of the 360
laboratories under american control
around the world
going back to ukraine
this uh by laboratories in kiev
and harkov were selected by
the
u.s
defense risk reduction agency not by
chance any studies
those who implemented the up8 project
focused on studying
pathogens of congo chromium fever
leptospirosis and antiviruses
believe that the interest of the
military biologists of the us is
specifically in those pathogens is
linked to the fact that they have they
are naturally present both in ukraine
and in russia and so that their use
could then be dressed up as a natural
outbreak of these diseases
on the basis of in the laboratory in
harcover there's also the p781 project
to study transmission to humans
of uh diseases through bats
in this context separate
attention should be paid to the
pentagon's choice of carrying out work
uh the contractors chosen to carry out
work in ukraine the black veatch company
this is not just any old company for
more than 100 years it's been working
for the american army it has built for
the army military bases including a
laboratory in los alamos uh to develop
nuclear weapons
and transmit
research into human transmission of
diseases through bats in ukrainian
biological laboratories was systemic
has been happening as a minimum since
2009 with a direct oversight of
specialists from the usa
during the implementation of these
projects
six families of viruses were identified
including coronaviruses and three types
of pathogenic bacteria
the pathogens from the plague brussels
and leptospirosis
these are the most attractive option to
use in order for infection
because they are resistant to medicine
and they spread very quickly from
animals to people
as part of the flu fly away project the
harkov institute of veterinary medicine
studied wild birds as a vector to
transmit avian flu at the same time they
assess those ways in which the
transmission process could become
uncontrollable
cause economic damage and create a risk
to food security
documents show the involvement of the
hakov institute
in the work to
collect strains of avian flu viruses
which are have high epidemiological
potential and could cross the species
barrier the russian ministry of defense
also has more and more new documents
about
the transfer of samples of blood serum
from ukrainian citizens to the territory
of third countries including to the uk
georgia and
germany the analysis of information
gives us grounds to say that the
ukrainian specialists were not informed
about the potential risks of transfer of
biological materials and are used and
are kept in the dark
i don't have a real idea about the real
objectives of the research being carried
out
and this is not surprising if according
to the contract documentation that i
mentioned earlier
they are simply playing a secondary role
data about attempts to destroy
biological materials and documentation
and ukrainian laboratories in order to
quickly wipe the traces of the
implementation of military and
biological programs we know that during
the
activities to destroy this uh
veterinary medicine laboratory in
hilleberg
town
citizens of ukraine the staff working
there weren't even allowed into the
building this laboratory
cooperates with the melchnikov
scientific research institute in odessa
where research is carried out
in
pathogens of the plague anthrax cholera
and tularemia
and attempts to wipe the traces of
biological waste from the laboratories
in clever dusk
these
waste was taken 120 kilometers towards
the western border towards tarutina and
berezino
the russian ministry of defense has
recorded all of this these information
to carry out a legal assessment further
down the line
the emergency emergency uh urgent
destruction of documents in herself
tree uh we believe that the reason for
this rush was their wish to hide from
russian specialists information about an
outbreak in 2019 in harrison of dero
filariasis it's a disease which is
spread by mosquitoes
the four cases of infection of this
disease were identified in february
which is not usual for the life cycle of
these insects
even to bearing in mind the incubation
period for the disease
at the same time we are aware that in
april 2019 a representative of the
pentagon visited the local institution
health institutions where they
learned of the results of the
epidemiological research and they were
able to copy the medical documentation
which are provided
ukrainian authorities with the support
of their western backers the western
media uh expressing doubts as regards of
reliability of the material that the
russian minister defense has published
i'd like to draw your attention to the
following
the documents that we found have a
signature a real signature of officials
from the u.s
particularly many of them are signed by
the head of the ukrainian office of the
threat to reduction agency joanna
wintrel
this is a pentagon staff member and a
well-known in not well known in
non-proliferation circles before ukraine
she supervised the destruction of
chemical weapons in libya if journalists
really are interested in the verifying
the documents that we provided then i
propose that you ask her directly is
that really her signature
i'd like to underscore once again here
talking not simply about the us and
ukraine's violation of the biological
weapons convention we're actually
talking about that there is more and
more proof that at the center of eastern
europe until the very last minute there
was a dangerous military biological
activity being carried out the
consequences of which at any time could
spread beyond the country and even into
the region
the scale of casualties
including um amongst the population of
ukrainian
of european countries in this case in
this scenario it's hard to imagine
coronavirus isn't could be nothing
compared with this
we're
there was a sharp spike in cases of
tuberculosis caused by a new
multi-resistant strain
during this math outbreak recorded in
the region in uh
more than 70 cases of infection were
recorded which quickly became lethal
this doesn't look like coincidence
like to comment on the statement made by
the representative of the u.n
secretariat
the secretary does not have information
about the implementation of military and
biological programs on the territory of
ukraine
in line with this bwc states parties
provide the un information about
facilities and biological activities
carried out
we're talking about confidence building
measures which are published in order to
monitor implementation of the convention
since 2006 which was when the these
projects started including the projects
up4 up8 and p781
the us and ukraine has been deliberately
keeping quiet about this in their
reports despite the clear military and
biological purposes of this
this is why russia for many years has
been calling for a strengthening of the
bwc regime and to adopt a legally
binding protocol to the convention which
would allow us to create an effective
mechanism of verification
and include in reporting from states
parties
information
on military biological activities
carried out abroad
20 years the us has been blocking this
kind of work refusing to provide this
kind of information
one other question
um
the representatives of the us have time
and time again
providing us with all of the facts
released today on the 11th of march are
only the tip of the iceberg our
ministry of defense is receiving more
and more material and we are not
analyzing them we will continue to keep
the international community informed
about the unlawful activity carried out
by the pentagon on the ukrainian
territory thank you for your attention
i thank the representative of russia for
his statement and give the floor to
albania
thank you mr president
let me express our shock on the sudden
passing away of a colleague of ours
ambassador jim kelly dpr violent and a
seasoned diplomat
we convey to our irish colleagues and to
jim's family our most heartfelt
condolences on this terrible loss
mr president
we thank usg nakamitsu for providing us
the same information as last friday on
this matter
we heard nothing new from the un
department of disarmament affairs of the
united nations
because there is nothing new
we take issues of weapons of mass
disruptions very very seriously
but still there needs to be an issue
mr president
we heard last friday and it was repeated
here
the united nations is not aware of any
alleged program in ukraine inconsistent
with international treaty obligations
including on chemical or biological
weapons
so what are we doing this morning
what are we talking about here for
non-existent chemical weapons programs
in what ukraine developed in
non-existent laboratories and financed
by non-existent programs
russian claims and we listen to
the statement remain unverified
unsubstantiated uncorroborated and not
independently verified
in a word
not credible
it is hard not to think then
and believe that today's meeting comes
as a last minute replacement out of an
easy pickup drawer
is therefore a loss of time and abuse of
the council
we are afraid to find ourselves in the
best case scenario with an attempt by
russia to try to shift attention from
its crimes and the stalling invasion to
by sowing fear with the dreadful
prospects of chemical warfare
or at the worst given russia's track
record of accusing other sovereign
crimes that they have been perpetrating
including in attempted assassinations
and poisoning of its own citizens
russia intends to use this information
tactics as a pretext for further
escalation and possible use of chemical
or biological weapons in ukraine
we have seen more than once
that the we have seen that the more the
invasion stalls the deadlier the missile
attacks and bombardments become
this is the real issue and the serious
one
let's remind ourselves colleagues that
russia has been saying one thing and
doing its opposite that russia is
blatantly breaking international law and
what whenever they speak about ukraine
they are just distorting reality
claims need to be properly and fully
investigated and we know how this is and
can be done
russia should first agree to an
immediate ceasefire throughout the
territory of ukraine
it should withdraw all military forties
within a radius of 40 kilometers of
suspected locations
ask that the u.n security forces secure
40 kilometers of radius to allow
diagnostic research teams to conduct
proper investigations
instead
we have the impression that russia
speaks to itself
dear colleagues with the sole exception
of russia everyone around this table
everyone without exception
as well as 140 140 members of the unga
have been clear on the absolute
necessity to respect the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine to stop
the war to protect civilians and to deal
with issues and concerns
not by bombarding indiscriminately not
by killing innocent people not by
destroying a country not by wrecking
economic harvard to the entire world but
through negotiations and through
diplomatic channels and mechanisms this
is what needs to be done
this
is what russia should be doing not
abusing the councils with pop-up
subjects of convenience trying to create
the illusion of truth out of repeated
lies
in bombash's words
something will always stick dear
colleagues
the world looks to the security council
and for good reason for hope and
solutions as the body responsible for
peace and security
it should not be abused for propaganda
and irrationality and i thank you
i thank the representative of albania
for his statement and give the floor to
the representative of the usa
thank you mr president
and thank you hi representative
nakamitsu for
joining us today to repeat what you gave
us
exactly what you gave us last week
and last week we heard from the russian
representative a tirade of bizarre
conspiracy theories
this week
we're hearing a whole lot more where
that came from things that sound like
they were forwarded to him on a chain
email from some dark corner of the
internet
president biden has a word
for this kind of talk milwaukee
as i said one week ago ukraine does not
have a biological weapons program
there are no ukrainian biological
weapons laboratories
not near russia's border not anywhere
they're only public health facilities
proudly and i say proudly supported and
recognized by the u.s government the
world health organization
and other governments and ins
international institutions
in fact
it is russia that has long maintained a
biological weapons program in violation
of international law
it is russia
that has a well-documented history of
using chemical weapons
it is russia who is the aggressor here
it was russian operatives who poisoned
alexi navalny and sergey and yulia
skripal
with nerve agents
it is russia that continues to support
the assad regime in syria and shield it
from accountability when the u.n and the
opcw have confirmed
that assad has recently used chemical
weapons over the past several years
let's not forget why why we are really
here today
we're here because russia
knew its cynical ploy to pass in a
culprit esculpatory resolution had
failed
this meeting is the result of their
isolation
on this council and on the world stage
we're not buying what they're selling
literally or figuratively
and i will reiterate the united states
deep and serious concern
that russia's calling for this meeting
is
is a potential false flag effort in
action
russia has repeatedly repeatedly accused
other countries of the very violations
it plans to perpetrate
we continue to believe it is possible
that russia may be planning to use
chemical or biological agents against
the ukrainian people
we aren't going to dignify russia's
disinformation are conspiracy theories
but we will continue to sound the alarm
and tell the world where we think russia
is heading
and we will remind the world that russia
has repeatedly
repeatedly lied to this council over
recent weeks
despite all the evidence we could see
with our own eyes it told us that it was
not going to invade ukraine
that it was engaged in war games
that it was interested in diplomacy
i asked the russian pr where are the
hundred thousand troops who were sitting
on the russian side of the border now
sadly
i think many of them have given their
lives in this senseless unconscionable
war against the ukrainian people
russia lied to its own people as well
shutting down media to try and hide the
truth
and i will not repeat the slurs and
false accusations that russia has hurled
against the ukrainian people and the
united states repeatedly at this table
but we know
that russia's disinformation
is a sign of its desperation
that's the truth
and we will continue to ensure the world
sees it and hears it
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of the united
states for her statement and give the
floor to the representative of ireland
thank you mr president
i wanted to
say at the beginning mr president how
much the irish delegation
appreciates the messages of condolences
we've received on the sudden loss of an
outstanding irish diplomat
colleague and friend
or yesh daigorava anam may he
rest in peace
mr president i would like to thank high
representative nakamitsu for her
briefing
ireland deeply regrets the decision of
the russian federation to call for
today's meeting
it has done so yet again for no other
reason than to promote its spurious
claims against ukraine and others
it is deeply troubling to hear the
russian federation spreading
unsubstantiated
unfounded allegations
the only so-called proof provided is to
point to transparent
projects necessary for
biosecurity
for human or animal health
research of the kind carried out by many
countries to advance global health
benefiting mankind
president i urge the russian federation
to cease its campaigns of disinformation
and attempt to distract from what is
really happening
because of its war in ukraine
this behavior is deeply this behavior is
disturbingly consistent
with the russian federation's own track
record of using disinformation and
multiple multilateral fora to dissemble
and deny its activities
russian military forces in ukraine
have already demonstrated
reckless disregard for nuclear safety
and security since the start of their
invasion
this pattern of recklessness raises real
fears
of a significant radiological chemical
or biological accident
it is unacceptable to make unfounded
accusations against ukraine
a state party in good standing to the
treaty on the non-proliferation of
nuclear weapons the chemical weapons
convention and the biological weapons
convention
president the use of chemical or
biological weapons in ukraine
would inflict untold additional
suffering
on the ukrainian people
who have already such heinous weapons is
immoral
and illegal in any circumstance
there will be no impunity for those who
use them
we urge the russian federation
not to violate or undermine the
essential multilateral disarmament and
non-proliferation instruments
upon which our collective security
depends
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of ireland
for her statement and give the floor to
the representative of france
mr president mr president
my condolences to the irish mission and
to the family of jim kelly who was an
exceptional colleague so the french
mission is alongside you and
we express to you our full friendship
mr president
i'd like to thank
ms nakamitsu for her briefing
i'll be very brief because everything
was already said last week
moreover i haven't heard any new
information this morning in any case no
new credible information
russia is indeed mounting
a disinformation campaign this meeting
is based on no established facts
ukraine has
no biological weapons program
it respects its obligations under the
biological weapons convention
the united nations clearly indicated
last week and again this morning that it
has no knowledge of the existence of
such programs
on the contrary russia has repeatedly
resorted to chemical weapons over the
last few years it has supported the
syrian regime
itself it has used these weapons in the
united kingdom and on its own territory
in targeted assassination attempts
by inventing an alternative
france is extremely concerned by the
possibility that this disinformation
campaign might be the prelude to the use
of a chemical or biological weapon in
ukraine if such attacks were to occur
there would only be one perpetrator that
would be russia
the use of these weapons
banned under international law would
constitute an intolerable escalation of
this conflict
the minister for europe and foreign
affairs jean ledrian has unambiguously
stated such attacks would lead to
even more massive economic sanctions in
response
finally i regret the fact that the
security council is being used by one of
its permanent members as a propaganda
platform
i thank the representative of france for
his statement and give the floor to the
representative of the uk
thank you mr president
and may i've joined others in expressing
our deep condolences to the irish
mission and to the family of jim kelly
he was an exceptional and very
well-loved colleague and we will miss
him thank you
i also
thank miss nakamitsu for her briefing
today
mr president only yesterday this council
discussed russia's invasion of ukraine
we heard from un briefers
the devastating impacts on ukraine its
people and its cities
on the region to which three million
refugees have fled
and on the wider international community
facing higher economic prices and the
consequences for countries
in need of this council's attention
today however
we've had a rehash
of amateurish disinformation which we
discussed and debunked last friday
it was nonsense then
and it is nonsense now
as i said then
laboratories in ukraine carrying out
research on public health hazards
are not
a threat to public to international
peace and security
by contrast
president putin's illegal and inhumane
invasion of ukraine
is the most significant threat to
international peace and security we face
today
so today's charade
is really not worthy
of a permanent member of the un security
council
the only thing
this council
needs to hear from the russian
federation
we didn't hear it yesterday we haven't
heard it today
the only thing this council needs to
hear
is that russia's troops are leaving
ukraine
ukraine does not want war
russians and ukrainians
soldiers civilians mothers children
are dying
russia
is isolated diplomatically
isolated economically and bogged down in
ukraine so we urge russia to stop this
invasion now
before any more damage is done in
ukraine
and also to russia i thank you mr
president
i thank the representative of the uk for
her statement and give the floor to the
representative of ghana
thank you mr president
my delegation would also like to convey
our sincere condolences to the family
and the irish mission on the sad pass in
the way of ambassador jim kelly
mr president my delegation is grateful
to the high representative for
disarmament affairs
izumi nakamitsu for her briefing to the
council
we have taken note of the information
provided to the council
once again we reaffirm our belief that a
conclusive determination of ukraine's
biological program can only be made
after due assessment by the relevant
internationally accredited bodies
as we previously stated the
weaponization of chemical or biological
agents in the war in ukraine or anywhere
else would be unconscionable and should
not be contemplated by any party
the international community must forge
consensus towards the establishment of a
verification regime for the biological
weapons convention in view of the recent
global developments including the
coveted 19 pandemic
we maintain that the possession or
proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction including chemical and
biological weapons neither assures
international peace nor national
security we must work collectively to
ensure the elimination of all such
weapons
what is present mr president is the need
for the cessation of hostilities and the
unconditional and immediate withdrawal
of the russian federation of all its
invading troops from the internationally
recognized borders of ukraine
increasingly this conflict is having
ramifications beyond the borders of
ukraine the consequent price hikes in
food and gas and gas are impacting in a
negative way the already fragile global
economy which is yet to recover from the
effects of the coveted 19 pandemic
by this unjustified war the lives of
many across the world have been put in
peril
we therefore welcome the secretary
general's intention to mobilize global
action to mitigate the impact of the war
and support all efforts to enhance
international solidarity
we bemoan the rapidly deteriorating
humanitarian situation and call on the
warring parties to respect and comply
with their commitments and obligations
under international law
international humanitarian law and human
rights laws
civilians must be protected from harm
civilian infrastructure must not be the
target of military bombardments safe
passage must be provided for the people
who are fleeing to safety
we call for an immediate end to the
attacks on medical and other critical
facilities and also call for the
protection of humanitarian and medical
personnel
mr president we encourage the sustenance
of the ongoing talks between the
negotiators of the two sides and hope
that they will yield an early
breakthrough for the peaceful settlement
of this conflict i thank you for your
kind attention
for her statement and give the floor to
the representative of brazil
thank you very much mr president
um let me begin as others in conveying
to our friends at the mission of ireland
are very very deep condolences for the
premature loss of ambassador jim kelly
i would
kindly ask the delegation to convey to
ambassador geraldine to all the mission
and to the family of jim kelly our deep
deep condolences
let me also
take this opportunity to thank high
representative nakamitsu for her
briefing
and before beginning mr president let me
kindly request
other members of the council to kindly
refrain
from attempting to interpret brazil's
position on any issue brazil is
perfectly capable of presenting its own
views
in this and in other bodies of the
united nations
mr president 50 years ago we adopted the
biological weapons convention
determined for the sake of humanity
to exclude completely the possibility of
biological agents and toxins being used
as weapons
we took that important step
and i quote the convention
convinced that such use would be
repugnant to the conscience of humankind
and that no effort should be spared to
minimize this risk end quote
today for the second time in a week we
gather here to once again discuss
extremely serious allegations
regarding the development production
and stockpiling of such abhorrent
weapons
as we stated last friday in brazil
believes that accusations of such
gravity
must be thoroughly substantiated by
solid evidence
which must be presented to
and confirmed by an independent and
impartial authority
as foreseen in article 6
of the biological weapons convention
brazil has long favored the negotiation
of a multilateral verification protocol
as a complement to the convention
with additional measures to guarantee
protection and security against emerging
biological threats
the situation before the council today
only reinforces the urgency and the
necessity to establish such a mechanism
mr president brazil looks forward to the
convini of the biological weapon
convention's ninth review conference
we need to restart negotiations on
strengthening the regime
including by establishing a verification
protocol
this will also be an opportunity to
deepen discussions on biosafety and
biosecurity
brazil is of the view
that legitimate scientific and
technological research
should be kept distinct and separate
from
possible violations of the prohibition
against the development and production
of biological weapons
if we wish to preserve the biological
weapons convention regime
research into new and dangerous
pathogens should be subject to strict
transparency mechanisms
finally i would like to reiterate what
we said last week
brazil condemns in the strongest
possible terms
the use or threat of use of all weapons
of mass destruction
including biological and chemical
weapons
anywhere
by anyone under any circumstances i
thank you mr
president i thank the representative of
brazil for his statement and give the
floor to the representative of kenya
thank you mr president we join others in
expressing our deepest condolences to
the mission of ireland and the family of
ambassador jim kelly over his shocking
demise
i thank miss izumi nakamitsu under
secretary general and high
representative of disarmament affairs
for her briefing
mr president it is it regrettable that
the armed conflict in ukraine rages on
at an intolerable cost to the people of
ukraine and increasingly to the entire
world especially the global south as
prices of essential commodities rise
sharply because of shortages and the
impacts of sanctions
we are gravely concerned by the
sustained targeting of civilians and
objects indispensable to the survival of
the civilian population including
residential homes health facilities
shelters as well as power and water
infrastructure in violation of
international law and international
humanitarian law
at this point mr president this council
should be focused on getting a cessation
of the military campaign in ukraine
we appeal to the concerns to do so
immediately to allow humanitarian action
and facilitate a much-needed dialogue
towards a sustainable political solution
any allegation of the development of
biological weapons in contravention of
the convention on the prohibition of the
development production and stockpiling
of biological weapons must not be taken
lightly
we call on all state parties to the
convention to make use of the
established mechanisms so that any
concern
or suspicion of the presence of these
extremely dangerous weapons can be
verified
in situations of armed conflict we must
point out that such verifications demand
a cessation of the conflict for it to be
carried out we urge state parties to the
convention on the prohibition of the
development production and stockpiling
of biological weapons to seize the
opportunity of the ninth review
conference later this year to strengthen
the biological weapons regime
in closing mr president kenya reaffirmed
its recognition of the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine i thank
you
i thank the representative of kenya for
her statement and give the floor to the
representative of norway
thank you president
let me also express our deepest
condolences to the irish mission for the
very sad passing our dear colleague jim
kelly
at the outset thanks to the high
representative nakamitsu for your
briefing
we were called here today at the request
of the russian delegation to again
discuss claims of a biological weapons
program in ukraine
yet we heard from the high
representative last week and it was
repeated today and i quote the united
nations is not aware of any biological
weapon programs in ukraine
russia has failed to offer any credible
evidence for its claims providing us
instead with unsubstantiated information
allegations and interpretations
we have trouble understanding the
rationale behind the last minutes call
to have further discussions today
we find it unacceptable that russia
continues to repeat its unsupported
claims that ukraine is preparing to use
biological weapons
it is becoming quite clear that this is
just another smokescreen tactic to draw
attention away from russia's role as
aggressor in this illegal invasion of
ukraine
president
norway remains a firm supporter of the
bio biological weapons convention and we
are determined together with parameters
in the national community
together with partners international
community to uphold a total ban against
biological weapons
norway can condemns any use of such
weapons
they cannot and must not be used under
any circumstances
this would constitute a clear violation
of international law
we deeply regret that russia by calling
these meetings seeks to undermine this
council and its vital role to peace
diplomacy
exactly eight years ago we were shocked
by the russian illegal annexation of
crimea
and no
russia is waging an unlawful war against
another u.n member state with
devastating humanitarian consequences
the sole responsibility for the war
falls on russia
russia must end it now thank you
i thank you representative of norway for
her statement and give the floor to the
representative of gabon
we would like to begin by expressing our
condolences to the irish mission
i'd like to thank
the main tenets of the statement of my
country in
light of the grave situation that is
raising
the risk of the incursion of chemical
weapons in the crisis in ukraine my
country calls for
parties to abide by the provisions of
the biological weapons convention which
formally prohibits the use of broad
spectrum of weapons as well as their
development production and stockpiling
my country as a member state to the
united nations convention on
the prohibition of biological weapons
reaffirms its commitment to
eradicating the use of biological
weapons and cause on the belligerents to
respect international law in this regard
reiterates its commitment to the
peaceful settlements of disputes between
united
nations member states and we continue to
call on parties to read the escalation
and to invest in ongoing negotiations in
good faith in order to bring an end to
this war of which the consequences are
already visible beyond ukrainian
territory thank you
i thank the representative of gabon for
his statement i give the floor to the
representative of india
thank you mr president
our deepest condolences are to the
family of ambassador jim kelly and
members of the irish mission
i thank usg nakamitsu for our briefing
we have carefully noted the points made
by usg regarding biological activities
relating to ukraine
india attaches high importance to the
biological and toxin weapons convention
as a key global and non-discriminatory
disarmament convention
prohibiting an entire category of
weapons of mass destruction
it is important to ensure full and
effective implementation of the
btwc
in letter and spirit
we also believe that any matter relating
to obligations under the convention
should be addressed as per the
provisions of the convention and through
consultations and cooperation between
the parties concerned
as outlined yesterday india remains
deeply concerned at the progressively
deteriorating situation in ukraine
we welcome the latest round of
diplomatic talks between the russian
federation and ukraine
we believe that immediate cessation of
hostilities and diligently pursuing the
path of dialogue and diplomacy is the
only way forward
it is important to undertake this
engagement keeping in mind the need to
respect the principles of the u.n
charter international law sovereignty
and territorial integrity of states i
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of india for
his statement i give the floor to the
representative of china
thank you mr president
express our deep sadness at the passing
of a dpr of ireland ambassador jim kelly
and extend our sincere condolences to
his family
and the colleagues of the irish mission
china has stated its position on the
ukraine issue many times
under the current situation it is the
shared desire of the international
community to achieve a ceasefire as soon
as possible
to avoid more civilian casualties and
prevent a massive humanitarian crisis
which is also what china is hoping for
direct negotiations between the parties
concerned are the fundamental way to
solve the problem russia and ukraine
have held four rounds of negotiations
and also they are staying
in touch with each other with
negotiations continuing there's hope for
ceasefire and a peaceful future
china will continue to
facilitate dialogue for peace we support
the united nations and all parties in
ramping up mediation efforts and hope
that all parties can do more things that
are conducive to promoting peace talks
rather than adding fuel to the fire
behind the ukraine crisis is the issue
of european security
it is our hope that the united states
and the european union and nato can sit
down with russia for in-depth and
comprehensive dialogue
and explore ways to put in place
a balanced effective and sustainable
european security architecture based on
the principle of indivisible security so
as to achieve lasting peace and
stability in europe
china's position on weapons of mass
destruction and biological security is
consistent
and clear
china stands for the complete
prohibition and the thyroid destruction
of all weapons of mass destruction
including biological and chemical
weapons
china resolutely opposes the development
possession or use of biological and
chemical weapons by any country under
any circumstances
and urges countries that haven't done so
to destroy their chemical weapons
stockpiles as soon as possible
complying with the biological weapons
convention is the obligation of all
state parties we call for early
negotiations on the establishment of a
bwc verification regime which will help
improve the global biosecurity
china was once a victim
of chemical and biological weapons
china believes that
any information
and lead on biological military
activities should trigger heightened
concern and attention of the
international community to avoid
irreparable harm
in this regard
relevant parties should take a
responsible approach
russia has further revealed the newly
discovered relevant documents
the party concerned should respond to
questions
and offer timely and comprehensive
clarifications to remove the doubts of
the international community
we do not consider it too much to ask
and on this issue
no
double standards should be applied
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of china for
his statement i give the floor to the
representative of mexico
thank you mr president
allow me to begin by joining those
those colleagues of ours in expressing
our most sincere condolences to
the irish delegation
for such an irreparable loss
we're grateful for the
briefing by high representative
nakamitsu and we take note of the
information that she has shared with us
particularly her reconfirmation that the
un has no knowledge of biological
weapons programs in ukraine
as we mentioned at a previous meeting
mexico believes that the convention on
the prohibition of the development
production and stockpiling of
bacteriological and toxin weapons
is the fundamental instrument of the
multi-natural disarmament regime to
address these matters
the convention contains
mechanisms for the resolution of
disputes through consultations and
cooperation
these should be used
where any state party
deems it necessary
don't you proceed along the terms of the
convention
the council can't be held hostage to
contradictory signs
one day one matter is raised the next
day
something's postponed the next day
it's substituted for something else
mexico will continue to be open to
dialogue and to constructive negotiation
however
to
move forward
there should be reciprocity
this effective commitment to dialogue
less than 24 hours have passed since the
last council meeting on
ukraine and the humanitarian needs
continue to grow
what is urgent
is
a cessation of hostilities
to ensure the unhindered supply of
humanitarian aid to whomever might need
it without restrictions or exclusions
thank you very much president
i thank the representative of mexico for
his statement
i shall now make a statement in my
capacity as the representative of the
united states
at the outset we express our deepest
condolences to the mission of ireland
over the passing
dpr mr jim kennedy
we express
our condolences to his family
i thank miss is
under any circumstances
is unjustified cannot be justified it is
an attack on humanity as a whole
the use of these prohibited weapons
requires an international response
those who are responsible for the use of
this weapons must be held accountable as
they constitute a violation of
international law the prohibition of
these weapons
including
through the convention on the
prohibition of biological weapons
is one of the most important
achievements of the international
community
maintaining the consensus
based upon which this prohibition was
established
is part of our responsibility to
maintain international peace and
security in conclusion
renews
its call to use all diplomatic tools
to alleviate the suffering of
civilians
a peaceful settlement of this conflict
according to international law
and
international humanitarian law
i resume my function as president of the
council
the representative of the russian
federation asked for the floor to make
an additional statement i give him the
floor
thank you very much president propaganda
propaganda
disinformation
amateurism
on
some statements are practically
literally repeated uh their statements
from the 11th of march yesterday
i haven't heard anything new in our
statement today
it's because you weren't listening to us
uh
but we provided new
[Music]
these documents
on the basis of cooperation between the
ukraine and the us
and the biological field
yesterday
you can verify what we've provided
then i'd ask you to come when you're
uploading i think
anyone who needs to be able to find this
if you want to
do so then do so when
don't make unfounded accusations of
russian propaganda but reply to the
questions that we asked
refusing to do so
simply because you've got nothing to say
rather than this you're trying to accuse
us
of intention
uh deploy biological chemical weapons
against ukraine
this is real cynicism isn't it
reward
chemical agents in some regions to carry
out a provocation and then accuse russia
of having done it
this is a false flag operation
i say
didn't listen to us properly
particularly the us
we didn't say as the representative of
the us claimed that ukraine ukraine
itself has a military biological
programmer
we said based on any documents that we
have
is something that the us itself has not
ukraine
ukraine and ukraine
in this case is being kept in the dark
and we already provided you with facts
we've talked you through them
in ukraine
dangerous lethal diseases
which there's no explanation for them
not usual factors they can't explain
that it could be linked to this kind of
activity though um
is the view and the demand
this was the u.n secretary of view but
already said that the u.n can't know
about this
secret military biological programmes
and those who carry them out are not
shared with the un or with anybody else
new facts have appeared and we will keep
the security council abreast as well as
international community
revealed in the near future thank you
very much
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for his statement
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned
okay
uh
okay
right next to that line so that the
cameraman
hello
our partners are in complete denial
they won't listen to what we are saying
they won't
accept
that we are presenting facts and not
just propaganda we circulated
new new materials about the issue
uh among the security council members
and the general assembly
and i'm sure that you will be able to
get access to those to those documents
they are not confidential secret and you
will make you will make your own mind
what whether it's
whether it's propaganda
and and
unsubstantiated accusations or whether
it's whether these are documents that i
was worth
commenting and replying which we didn't
hear today today we heard the same the
repetition of what they said uh of what
our partners said in the meeting of the
11th of march they refused to accept and
to to recognize that we presented new
set of evidence of of military
biological uh programs that
that were conducted in ukraine with with
the participation of pentagon and now i
would like i would like to give the
floor to my first deputy to make a
special announcement
yes uh hello everybody i just wanted to
announce that my twitter was blocked
today and i received a message from the
client service saying that i am
violating the rules of twitter
and i am engaged in abuse and harassment
so the tweet is like this
that's how fake news is born we want we
warned in our statement back on 7 march
that the hospital in mariupol had has
been turned into a military object by
radicals very disturbing that u.n
spreads this information without
verification that was my tweet so it's
abuse and harassment according to
twitter
i will open account in telegram and you
will receive
english version
link to this account this is very
deplorable and this clearly illustrates
how much alternative view and free free
press and free information is valued by
twitter and in this country thank you
very much this is a new interpretation
of the word harassment as well
thank you
uh
um